Reconvening the open session and in closed session the board
discussed and took action on the following legal matters.
Napa Valley Unified School District versus California
State Board of Education, California School Boards
Association's Education Legal Alliance versus California
State Board of Education.
Item 17 is the next item on the agenda.
It is the action to set aside the State Board of Education's
September 15th, 2022, reversal of the denials of the Maya
Commons Charter Middle School petition to comply with a writ
of mandate to be issued by the Sacramento Superior Court in
Napa Valley Unified School District versus California
State Board of Education and California School Boards
Association's Education Legal Alliance versus California
State Board of Education.
As of this morning, no judgment or writ has issued.
The board has received a request from counsel for Maya
Commons Charter Middle School to withdraw item 17 because the
school intends to immediately appeal the judgment and writ to
be entered by the court in both cases.
Counsel for the school has represented that its filing of
the notice of appeal will automatically stay the court's
judgment and writ that would require the board to take
certain actions within 30 days of the writ's issuance.
Yesterday the school filed notices of appeal in both cases.
In light of these developments, the board will not take up
item 17 at this meeting and it will be withdrawn from the
agenda.
Moving on to the next item, which is the waiver consent
calendar, we need the public comment slide up for the
waivers.
Thank you.
There we go.
Now I'd like to take up the waiver consent items W1 through
W14.
We'll now open the phone line for the public comment queue and
we will give a little wait time.
First we'll ask if there's any in-person public comment.
Nobody has signed up for public comment.
Okay.
And are there any speakers signed up to provide public
comment?
We do have a few callers in the queue.
I'm going to remind the callers that we are currently taking
public comment up for items W1 through W14.
And I will open the phone line now.
Caller with the last four digits, 8331, you are now live.
Please start your public comment.
Okay.
Hearing none, caller with the last four digits, 2181, you are
now live.
Please start your public comment.
My name is Kathy Matthews.
I'm a grandmother with a grandchild who I will be
sending to my commissary several years.
I support this school.
The two existing middle schools are totally different.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry to interrupt.
That item has been withdrawn.
We are currently taking public comment up for W1 through W14.
And it looks like that concludes public comment.
All right.
Given that there's no further public comment, I'll ask for a
motion on consent items waivers 1 through 14.
Do I have a motion?
Member Rodriguez, do I have a second?
Member Olken, thank you very much.
A show of hands for those in favor.
Please keep your hands up until they're counted.
And for UDL purposes, we'll say aye.
Any opposed?
Say nay.
Any abstentions?
All right.
The motion carries.
Thank you.
Item 12 is the California's Bipartisan Safer Communities
Act Stronger Connections Grant Program proposal.
The approval of the criteria to define high needs.
And I will turn this over to Lisa Borrego of the CDE.
Lisa, please begin.
Good morning, everyone.
Yes, we can.
It is a little low, however.
Yes.
Okay.
Good morning, everyone.
Good morning, Board President Darling-Hammond, Vice
President Glover-Woods, Board members and Chief Deputy
Nicely.
My name is Lisa Borrego, Director of the Whole Child
Division.
I will be presenting on board item number 12,
Bipartisan Safer Communities Act Stronger
Connections Grant Program.
Here with me today are Nancy Kim Portillo, Deputy
Superintendent of Public Instruction, and Dr.
Tom Herman, Education Administrator of the
School Health and Safety Office.
Tom's office will be responsible for
administering the Stronger Connections Grant for the
California Department of Education.
The California Department of Education recommends that
the SBE approve the criteria for the definition of
high need LEA as required in the Californians
Bipartisan Safer Communities Act Stronger
Connections Grant Program pending the SBE Executive
Director approval of final revisions requested by the
SBE, correction of any typographical errors, and
necessary non-substantive clarifying edits.
President Biden signed the Bipartisan Safer
Communities Act in June 2022 to address the epidemic
of gun violence in schools and communities.
Congress authorized one billion dollars in
formula funding under Title IV, Part A of the
Elementary and Secondary Act for state educational
agencies to provide safer and healthier learning
environments for students.
The Bipartisan Safer Communities Act provides one
billion dollars to be awarded in competitive
grants to high need LEAs to establish safer and
healthier learning environments.
This is called the Stronger Connections Grant
Program.
The Bipartisan Safer Community Act specifies
that state education agencies must make
competitive grants to high need LEAs to support
activities under Section 4108 of the Elementary and
Secondary Education Act.
California was awarded one hundred and nineteen
million dollars.
One hundred and thirteen million dollars of this
grant will be awarded to LEAs through a
competitive process.
The purpose of the grant is to increase school
safety, address mental health needs of students,
and promote the emotional and physical well-being
of all students.
States are encouraged to award funding to LEAs
that prioritize social-emotional learning
programs and practices, trauma-informed
practices, identification and referral, initiatives
that reduce exclusionary discipline approaches such
as restorative practices, systemic efforts to
transform school climate by reducing punitive school
discipline practices, and increasing support for
pro-social behaviors.
LEAs will outline their planned use of funds in
the request for application.
Under the U.S. Department of Education published
guidance, the state education agency must
define high-need LEA for purposes of eligibility
for the Stronger Connections Grant Program and
is encouraged to provide the public with an
opportunity to comment and provide input related to
the grant implementation.
Further, they encourage states to use a measure of
poverty in their definition of high-need LEA and to
consider other elements such as chronic absenteeism,
exclusionary discipline, referrals to the juvenile
justice system, substance use, lack of mental
health staff, and exposure to natural disaster.
The charge is to identify a definition of high needs
that is reflective of an LEA's lack of resources to
address the health and safety of all students.
This definition is not intended to identify the
LEAs with the greatest safety issues.
To be clear, as we submit this proposed definition
of high needs, we do not assume that a lack of
resources means a community is more violent.
Rather, our purpose in proposing this definition
is to increase equity and resources through this
grant in combination with other recent efforts like
the Community Schools Partnership Program to
strengthen assets and add resources in areas where
decades of disinvestment has had deep educational impacts.
To meet the requirement to provide the public with
notice and a reasonable opportunity to comment and
to maximize input from education partners across
the state, the CDE designed and distributed a survey.
The survey asked respondents to rank the
importance of the proposed elements of high need and
to prioritize strategies and approaches to safety
and student outcomes.
The survey was sent electronically on June 6,
2023, and closed on June 12, 2023.
The survey was sent to educational partner groups,
including, but not limited to, state and federal
program directors, school safety partners from all
counties, school districts, mental health partners,
and service providers.
CDE received 343 responses.
Seventy-seven percent of respondents indicated that
a chronic absenteeism rate higher than the state
average was of high importance to defining high need.
Eighty-two percent of the respondents indicated that
adding or increasing staff within an LEA whose
primary purpose is to address the mental health
needs of students is a priority strategy and
approach to improving student outcomes.
In formulating the definition of high need,
we considered several factors, including
available statewide and comparable data, survey
results, as referenced in slide 10, definitions
used by other states, and the proposed request for
application components.
For example, while a criterion on access to
mental health staff was of interest, California does
not have a statewide comparable metric to
measure this, which makes it more appropriate for
discussion by the applicant in their request
for application.
As mentioned, we also looked into definitions
used by other states.
Nevada used a high rate of poverty and one of the
following characteristics.
High rates of chronic absenteeism, students
experiencing transiency or homelessness, referrals
to the juvenile justice system.
Colorado used the percentage of students
eligible for free and reduced lunch, student to
mental health ratios, and rate of chronic absenteeism.
Finally, the request for application will allow us
to capture additional local data that will help
determine the allocation of these funds.
As a result, the following represents the proposed
definition of high need for your consideration.
LEAs with a concentration of 80% or above of
students from low income families, English learners
and students in foster care, plus one or more of
the following characteristics.
Unduplicated pupil count.
A chronic absenteeism rate higher than the state
average, an exclusionary discipline in and out of
school suspension rate higher than the state
average, a school stability rate lower than the
state average, and a dropout rate higher than
the state average.
With the combination of the use of a high unduplicated
pupil percentage and one of the additional
eligibility criteria such as high suspension rates
and the local context provided in the request
for application, we hope to provide a significant
amount of funding to LEAs who want to improve their
school climate for a safer campus who may not
otherwise have access to resources to do so.
For clarification purposes, I do want to mention that
unlike community schools implementation grants,
eligibility for this grant is at the LEA level rather
than at the school level.
In other words, LEAs that qualify under the high
needs definition approved by the board would
determine which of their schools they will seek
funding for in their request for application.
We anticipate providing further guidance and
clarification for the school site selection process
as we finalize the request for application in
collaboration with SBE.
Based on the proposed definition of high needs,
CDE conducted a data run to determine the number of
LEAs that would be eligible along with some
additional highlights.
624 LEAs would be eligible under the proposed
definition of high need.
Within those LEAs, 3,228 schools under eligible
LEAs including charter and non-charter schools
would be eligible.
In addition, eligible LEAs are distributed
throughout the state representing diverse
geographic regions and both urban and rural communities.
The competitive application process will
encourage eligible LEAs to utilize specific local
data points or indicators such as mental health
needs, bullying, harassment, community and
school violence and substance use to establish
the gaps and needs that will be addressed
through this grant program.
The competitive process will allow LEAs to
improve to provide information about their
specific health and safety needs.
The draft request for application that was
included at the time of the agenda posting for the
July meeting does not reflect a new requirement
of the 2023 budget act which requires that
LEAs implementing MTSS, multi-tiered systems of
support, be prioritized for these grants.
The multi-tiered system of support prioritization
will be included in the final request for
application along with directions of how LEAs
can document their multi-tiered system of
support process as part of their submission.
CDE, in collaboration with SBE, will use the
request for application process to ensure that
schools and communities demonstrating the highest
need are prioritized and that requests for
application submission requirements mitigate
against potential disproportionate advantages
or disadvantages for particular LEAs resulting
from the federal requirement to qualify
applicants at the LEA level.
CDE will work closely with SBE staff to ensure
alignment and integration of this new language
along with developing subject to approval by
the executive director of the State Board of
Education the request for application process.
Additionally, we have heard from educational
partners about the timeline in the posted
draft request for application and will
adjust the submission timeline to ensure that
all eligible LEAs have the opportunity to apply.
Eligible LEAs will apply on behalf of their
selected schools.
As mentioned previously, unlike community schools,
eligibility for this grant is determined at the
LEA level rather than at the school level.
LEAs will receive between $150,000 to $400,000
for each selected school.
Allocation is based on school enrollment.
The amounts are designed to give schools enough
resources to affect change.
The funding will be allocated to awarded LEAs
annually for two years.
All grant funds need to be expended by September
2026.
In closing, the California Department of
Education recommends that the SBE approve the
criteria for the definition of high need
LEA as required in the California's Bipartisan
Safer Communities Act Stronger Connections
Grant Program pending the SBE executive director
approval of final revisions requested by the SBE
correction of any typographical errors and
necessary non-substantive clarifying edits.
This concludes our presentation and we are
happy to answer any questions.
Thank you very much.
First I want to ask our liaison, well first I
want to ask you to put the public comments slide
up which you have.
Members of the public wishing to provide
comment may do so in person or by calling the
telephone number and using the access code provided
on the slide that is shown now.
And while we're waiting for members of the public
to call in, I want to ask our liaison member
Escobedo if he has any initial comments then
we'll see if we have clarifying questions on
the board before we go to public comment.
Member Escobedo.
I just wanted to note that I do believe that the
indicators we saw in front of us on duplicate
accounts and high chronic absenteeism and
reduced lunch are indicators that I do
believe helps us identify which schools are worthy
for safer community grant.
However, I just want to also share that just because
we have a high rate of chronic absenteeism or we
have high poverty, safety is an important aspect
for all schools no matter what the poverty rate.
In fact, a lot of the violence occurs in schools
where you have a very affluent population.
Most of the shootings actually occur in non-urban
school settings so I just wanted to share that.
But looking at the requirements as we see in
this grant, I do applaud CEE for their efforts in
creating the criteria but I just want to make sure
that safety belongs for every school no matter
what these indicators look like.
So just wanted to share those thoughts from my
perspective.
Thank you.
Are there any clarifying questions before we go to
public comment?
Yes, member Patilla Bronson.
So as you were describing the potential criteria, I
think that you said something about not using
community level violence as an indicator based on
federal guidance but I just wanted to clarify.
So the recommendation that's being put forth to
the SBE takes into consideration three
indicators not of one of which is community
violence.
That indicator or that local information can become
a part of the applicant's RFA in describing the
communities and the schools that they'll be
applying for.
So they can use that local level data to be able to
share and present their story on why they're
recommending their school site to be funded through
this program.
There's not a federal prohibition on actually
using that for our eligibility criteria for
the RFA.
Is that correct?
I'm going to ask, excuse me, I'm asking my technical
assistant to support Dr. Herman.
Thank you.
Tom Herman, administrator of the School Health and
Safety Office.
That is correct that there is no prohibition against
using the community violence indicators.
It's just that we felt it would be fair to use those
indicators that are collected statewide and
then those other local indicators such as substance
abuse, community violence, youth risk behaviors in
schools that they would form part of the RFA to
become part of that competitive process.
Just a brief one.
I thought you might have said, but I wasn't, I
didn't hear quite clearly.
Did you say that we were, you were going to adjust
the RFA timeline to allow all LEAs to apply?
That is correct.
Do we know what that timeline is yet?
No, we'll be working with the SB staff to identify
what that timeline will look like.
Thank you.
Member Olken, did you have the same question?
It looked like you had a question too.
Okay.
All right.
We have a few minutes here, so we're going to go
to public comment.
Is there any public comment in the room?
You guys can take a rest if you want for a minute
because I don't know if we'll have any public
comment.
Don't get too comfy.
There's no public comment in the room.
All right.
Is there any on the phone?
Yes.
We have one caller.
Caller with the last four digits, 4270.
You are now live.
Please start your public comment.
Thank you.
Madam Chair, members, excuse me, Madam President
and members, Leigh Ann Giller Reed on behalf of
the Small School Districts Association.
I want to thank the department for acknowledging
the timeline, which was a little bit untenable
for everyone, but particularly small districts
who don't often have the capacity to do a grant
in the timeline, such as was proposed.
And we look forward to working with the
department to ensure that small districts
can play a part because those community services
may not are even more overstressed in some of
those rural areas.
So we look forward to working with you and
thank you again for adjusting the timeline.
And we are here to help in any way we can.
Thank you.
That concludes public comment for item number 12.
So we're now open for board discussion.
Questions or comments?
Yes, I remember Tilo Bronson and then member
Roscoe Gonzalez.
So I just wanted to start by saying I think this
is such a necessary and important area of focus
and I'm so grateful that you all have put this
together to actually think about how to make sure
that these funding sources are directed to the
right places.
I'm a little, I'm trying to grapple with the lack
of a community violence indicator, which I think
would be, would hit it most on the nose.
And in prior work, there are state indicators
that are collected around community levels of gun
violence by zip code.
The, I'm going to pull up the stat as soon as my
phone opens up.
It is, it used to be the Office of Statewide
Health Planning and Development that has been
renamed in the 22 budget as the Department of
Health Care Access and Information and they have
a statewide database of firearm related
hospitalizations.
The level of community violence, particularly
that young people experience in high violence
community, I think is, should be, I think,
lifted up.
And it is, it's not, I think, quite the same as
thinking about community level poverty, which I
think is important, valuable and certainly
relevant.
But because we have particular school sites
and LEAs where the levels of PTSD rival that of
war zones, I think it is relevant to actually have
an indicator that captures that information.
So my suggestion would be that that be elevated as
among the definitions of high need as we're
thinking about a pot of funding that is about
community level violence and safety.
And I'd be happy to send you the sort of data
sources, but it's a state agency.
So.
Roscoe Gonzalez.
Well, and make sure I get here.
And considering that the funded activities may
involve providing mental health services,
encouraging community involvement, establishing
programs to prevent students from dropping out,
implementing nighttime bully initiatives,
purchasing security equipment, reducing chronic
absenteeism in elementary schools, providing early
intervention for middle school students,
behavioral mental health challenges.
When I was reading all this, I thought about will
LEAs be encouraged to create synergy with
community school grants that have been awarded
because it seems like it would be something that
goes together.
The question again is will LEAs be encouraged to
create synergy with community schools grants
that have been awarded?
Yes, thank you.
We are building that into the RFA that districts
indicate the extent to which they're having
systems in place that are school wide that include
community involvement and other initiatives that
they currently have related to this.
This grant itself is related to title four,
part A of ESSA.
It's separated fiscally, but it is nonetheless many
of the same topics.
And so related to the ones you just mentioned.
Great, thank you.
And I'm also just add that I'm happy to hear that
the timeline is being worked on because I wanted
to be able to give opportunities to LEAs to
have enough time to apply, especially rural
communities that don't have the resources for
these grant writing teams, so thank you.
I'd just like to piggyback on that and then I'll
see if there are any other questions or comments.
It would be great if in both helping people think
about that we can also try to structure the
reporting and so on so that it is more efficient
for districts because they're getting hit with a
lot of, you know, management monitoring,
reporting things, and I know that this is federal
so that adds its own, you know, wrinkle to it,
but if you can keep that in mind as you're also
helping people think about how to integrate the
work that they're doing.
The bill itself allows for a large range of fund
uses from sort of school hardening practices to,
you know, more supportive practices to create a
stronger climate and mental health setting,
and it might be useful in the RFA when you get to
that to be either providing some of the
research or asking districts to, you know,
locate their plans in the evidence about what is
most supportive of school safety so that...
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Are there any other questions or comments?
I don't know if I need to actually propose a motion
in order to append something on gun-related
hospitalizations as a factor.
Hospitalizations?
Gun-related.
Oh, gun-related, yeah.
Community violence and I don't know...
Well, let's come back around to that.
We have another discussion coming from
Member McQuillin and then we can come back to that
question before we get to a motion.
Yes, thank you for bringing this forward.
You mentioned a consideration on the
timeline for the application for additional
time for rural districts.
Were there any other considerations for the
disbursement and, you know, equitable disbursement
for rural districts also?
Yeah, thank you for that question.
We've been in contact with rural districts and part of,
as you know, part of the issue has been when it's
based merely on ADA that they sort of suffer from
that because they're not given enough funds to
really affect systemic change and so we're
looking at a minimum threshold of 150,000
currentlys are thinking about a school so
regardless of their size that they would be given
enough money to affect change that is long lasting
and systemic.
As well, I should note that there would be a cap
equally on larger districts so that they
would not sort of gobble up all of the funds so
that there would be a cap on the very large
districts to allow us to be more equitable with the
disbursement of the funds.
Member Olken.
Thank you.
I just wanted to ask a clarifying question
related to member Patil Bronson's potential amendment.
So I thought I heard when you were presenting that
the reason there wasn't a specific indicator related
to community violence was related to the fact there
isn't a comparable measure statewide and I just
wonder if you could talk about that a little bit
and then maybe I misheard that.
And then also clarify if the description of
community violence or community violence is
built into the application but isn't an indicator,
how would it actually be considered?
I'm sorry, could you repeat just the letter?
So if those who are applying are able to address
and speak to the conditions of the community
and particularly related to violence but it isn't
a specific indicator in the application, how would
it actually be considered when judging and trying
to determine who would receive the funding?
Sure, thank you.
That's a great question.
So it would be addressed in the RFA itself in the
rubric in terms of so evaluating the extent to
which those LEAs applied for funds, the extent to
which they're matching their proposed activities
with what their needs are.
And so if their needs are such that students are
experiencing trauma and so forth associated with
community violence, they would indicate that
along with the local data that they're getting
from that.
So it would be built into the rubric for
assessment, just we wouldn't be looking for a
specific measure that they have to quote because
there maybe isn't one across the entire state.
That's correct.
The current configuration of it that high need
would be established through only those
indicators that the CDE collects statewide to be
fair.
Got it, thank you.
I think at this point I want to come back to
Member Patilo Bronson about the data, the indicator
that you were talking about, but we're all getting
on the same page about that.
Yeah, so the California Department of Healthcare
Access and Information tracks firearm related
hospitalizations, which I think is a particularly
relevant measure of community violence in part
because it's available statewide.
It's at the zip code level.
So school district could easily aggregate the data
based on its zip codes in its attendance zones.
But it also I think in some ways is a truer
picture of a lack of community safety that kids
experience in their lives.
In my normal day job, I work on community violence
initiatives and the White House, for example, had
just hosted a community violence farm and
initially looked at firearms incidences relating
in death.
But obviously when kids are shot, when people in a
community are shot with regularity, that has an
incredible impact on mental health, even if someone
does not die.
And so I think what's really helpful about the
Department of Healthcare Access and Information's
data on this topic is that it actually gives a fuller
picture of gun violence that might be weighing on a
kid's home environment, community environment.
And I'd be happy to send the website links.
And are you thinking to propose that that should
be one of the criterion for eligibility?
So I think it's a two part if on slide 12, I think
basically the LCFF factors are kind of the first
function.
And then there's a list of additional characteristics
around chronic absenteeism, exclusionary
discipline.
And my proposal would be to add gun related
hospitalizations as a factor to be considered
below that among the bullets.
So that's the amendment you would like to make to the
high need categories.
I think one thing we would just like to note, if I
may, is we do not know enough about the data set
and would be challenged to figure out the overlay
of zip code and LEA boundaries in a short
timeline.
However, again, that information could be
utilized in the development of their narrative
associated with the schools that they would be
selecting to be considered for the application.
So it is just something we'd want to make note of.
I wonder, so there's criteria to apply, which is
the front gate to get in.
And I wonder whether schools that might be high
need on this variable, which is the one that's
most related to safety, might be excluded by the
other criteria.
Well, so one way to use this criterion is to say
once you get in the door of these measures, then you
can also speak to the gun related hospitalization
rate.
But I mean, this is just a pondering.
There may be schools that have very high gun
related hospitalization rates that would not be
eligible based on these criteria.
But there are communities, to your point, there are
communities that could choose to use that data
information to help explain their narrative for
that selection of schools, while also considering
the other indicators that we're proposing in the
definition.
These bullets below are not additive, right?
They're not requiring in an application process
that they have high rates of all of the bullets,
right?
That's correct.
It's the concentration of 80 percent or above of
students from low income families, English learners
and students in foster care, plus one of the
following.
So it would be any of those indicated there.
And those would be determined by the state
education data set.
So are you comfortable with the notion that the
criterion, maybe I shouldn't use the word
criterion, that the consideration of the gun
related hospitalization rate would come later as
something that people could suggest?
I think the current proposal already has that
baked in as a later almost description that would
be in the application.
Part of why I'm pushing for it to be here is this is
ostensibly a funding pot that's about community
level violence.
And I think it's important to have that lifted up.
If a school district doesn't have ready access or
has so many zip codes to pull that it feels
onerous, they can certainly use any of these
other criteria because there's already four that
they could choose from.
But I actually think that enabling a school
district to share a more clear view of the levels
of community violence that their students face is
pretty important for a funding pot that's
actually about community violence.
Thank you for your comment.
I just would want to again make note that we are
trying, as we think about what eligibility looks
like for all LEAs within the state, we want to
assure that they had access to available
statewide and comparable data that would equalize
their ability to be eligible for this grant.
So those were factors that were considered when
these recommendations for the definition of high
needs was determined.
And again, recognize that there were other local
information that could be shared at the time in
development of their narrative within the LEA
application process, RFA application process, that
would allow us to have a better understanding of
what some of the nuances that you're describing
might look like in communities.
Yes, Member Escobedo.
And Trustee Bronson, I have similar feelings, but
understanding that keeping the data consistent and
for it to fit federal guidelines, I believe, is
my understanding why these indicators were
selected, although I completely on the same
wavelength that you that we need to look at other
local indicators.
And obviously that can be, it could hopefully
increase the level of awareness for those
districts that are interested in applying for
the grant, knowing full well that those specific
indicators are really the gatekeepers for
eligibility for this grant.
So thank you for bringing that up.
Really appreciate it.
I see Member Yoshimoto-Tari.
I just have a hard time hearing there's an echo
on the side, so could you just repeat the name of
the source of the data that you were suggesting,
Member Bertillo-Bronson, please?
It's the California Department of Health
Care Access and Information.
It used to be the California, it had a prior
name until 2022.
It used to be the Office of Statewide Health
Planning and Development, and they changed their name.
Is it not an official California government
department?
No, no, no, it's, I mean, it's a statewide
department and it's statewide data, so it's
got the data runs for the entire, it's got it by
zip code across the state.
I think what I'm hearing about the concern of our
CDE colleagues is that that's not in what we
would download generally from the state education
database to determine who the eligible pool is,
but I'm not all so clear why a district couldn't
bring that and say, here is our bullet in the
criterion.
You know, we have more than 80% of what I think
is on duplicate account students, and we have a
very high rate of government-related
hospitalizations and here's the data, you know,
or here's the link to the data, whatever.
So I'm not clear whether this is an
inconvenience or a fatal flaw to bring in another
agency's data.
I ask the question because it is a California.gov
URL, and I think at a higher, like 30,000 foot
level, it, from a school site's perspective, I
think agencies of the state can do a service to
those of us working in different sectors to help
integrate the data.
So I'm hearing in this case that maybe these data
aren't available by school district boundaries,
they're only available by zip code as one of the
barriers for us.
But I think in a larger context, as we start
thinking about integration of services and
supports on behalf of schools, it's a larger
ask to see if the Department of Education
might be able to work with this department.
And it may not be in time for this RFA, but to work
with this department to see if there can be
collaboration to get this kind of data in
boundaries of our school districts and our LEAs.
Well, let the districts be the ones who bring it
with the evidence that they've assembled.
There are occasional districts that are not,
you know, that cut across partial zip codes,
which is, you know, what is a little bit messy.
But there also are plenty of districts that might,
you know, qualify on this basis and, you know,
would be very clean.
So I think we want to be sure that that's in the
consideration because these are interesting
indicators, but they're not particularly tightly
tied to community-related violence.
And particularly with the chronic absenteeism
indicator, which we talked about yesterday, you
know, you could be identifying places that
had a lot of snow or a lot of flooding, but that's
not something that is, you know, necessarily
connected to the need that they have for these
resources.
Yeah, and I think those are great considerations.
The issue, I think, at hand is that sort of
coordinating that data might push out the timeline
further in terms of establishing the
eligibility, in terms of getting the grant
implemented.
I would want to suggest, too, that there is so
much great local data that is very, very related
to the intent of the grant, and those are
students' mental health needs, their
perceptions of safety, their experience with
trauma, their suicide ideation, their sorts of
feelings of sadness and hopelessness and
disconnected to their school.
And we're seeing such strong data in this post
COVID as students have returned.
And this grant addresses those issues, and those
local needs can be established in their RFA,
along with the activities that they're
suggesting to improve those outcomes.
Yes.
A clarifying question.
Does the federal guidelines hold you to the
80% threshold for the unduplicated count?
I'm just thinking about maybe smaller, real
small rural districts that may have difficulty
reaching that 80%, but may have one of those
other factors present.
Is that a stronghold?
No, that is something that the CDE could
determine.
So they don't, it's not, the 80% isn't a
strict thing from the Department of Education.
RFA to see if a district could apply if they're
under the 80% threshold of a small rural district,
and then it's just based on the application.
I'm sorry.
No, that's okay.
Did you hear me?
Did you hear the question?
Yes.
So the item in front of you today is actually to
determine and approve the definition of HINIE,
which would include that the LEA that applies
must be at 80% or above.
So consideration, if your question is, does the 80%
have to be the threshold that we're recommending
and SBE approves, that would be for discussion.
That could be considered, but there is no federal
guidance that mandates that it be 80%.
It's our recommendation.
Based on ensuring equity, conducting data runs and
determining that there would be access for our
rural school communities to have eligibility under
this criteria at the time of submission.
So the 522 that are listed there, they meet the 80%
threshold?
That is correct.
Under those numbers provided to you, they not
only meet the 80% and or they meet one of these
recommended criteria.
So that ensures that those numbers are actual
numbers that ensure that that would be eligible
LEA's who would be able to apply under the under
this particular recommended definition of HINIE.
Thank you.
And I just sent you the website.
Who?
Actually, I sent it to Brooks.
OK, so I guess we're at a point where we've
raised a lot of considerations and we may
need a motion.
And I'm wondering if we should maybe make the
motion around the recommendation with an
encouragement to consider the ways in which this
additional data could be incorporated so that they
can really kick the tires on that.
I appreciate that this is a real time discussion
we're having and you guys have not had a chance to
look at a sister agency's data, so I'd be happy to
phrase it as a consideration of and provided
it meets sort of the metrics that you all need
for statewide comparability.
I think that would be great.
Sorry, so I am what are you doing to enable
consideration of gun related violence metrics
that are available through state agency reporting?
And there's a couple of sources actually that
track it so you can choose which one you like the
best.
So you're moving an amendment before we get to
the motion.
So I think we would then need a second for the
amendment and then we can vote on the amendment
and then we'll vote on the motion.
Is that right?
Or you want to fold that in with them?
I guess we should not fold it in with the motion.
Let's just vote on the amendment.
She could vote the recommendation with that
amendment.
I will vote for in favor of the recommendation,
which generally I think is fantastic.
And with the amendment for consideration of gun
related violence metrics to be included based on
considerations of statewide data consistency as
plausible as possible and per your discretion.
And I would love to hear back actually.
We have a motion.
All right.
Thank you.
Any other discussion of the motion?
All in favor say aye and raise your hand.
All right.
Any opposed nay.
Any abstentions?
Motion carries.
Thank you very much.
And with that, because we've done so much good
work this morning, I'm going to give you a 15
minute break and then we'll come back and finish
our business for the day.
We have a very relaxed schedule today.
Hey, welcome back.
We're going to move ahead with item 13.
Item 13 is a public hearing regarding the
appeal from an action of the Santa Clara County
Committee on School District Organization to
disapprove a petition to transfer territory from
the San Jose Unified School District to the
Oak Grove Elementary School District and the
Eastside Union High School District.
And this item will be presented by Larry Shirey
of the CDE.
Nice to see you again, Larry.
You may begin.
Thank you.
Good morning, everyone.
Again, Larry Shirey, School Facilities and
Transportation Services Division.
As you just heard, we have an appeal from the
Santa Clara County territory transfer that
was turned down by the county committee there.
The transfer was to move two homes from San Jose
Unified to Oak Grove Elementary and the
Eastside Union High School District.
At the time that they heard this locally, there
was only one student involved.
Currently, there are two.
And the students in question have never, ever
attended San Jose Unified.
They've always been attending Oak Grove
Elementary School or I think actually Evergreen
Elementary School early on on inter-district
transfers.
So there are a couple of peripheral issues I'd
like to address regarding this before we move
into the actual consideration.
One is that you may have read in the item that
we're calling this uninhabited territory.
That may seem a little odd since there are people
living here, but uninhabited territory is a
legal term.
It's in the Education Code, the Government Code,
Public Resources Code.
And the purpose is just to identify very small
areas and prevent absurd responses to them, like
calling elections for two people, a county election
for two people.
For our purposes, it just means that the proposal
gets started by an owner petition rather than a
voter petition, a petition signed by 25% of the
voters in the area.
Secondly, as we discussed briefly yesterday, the
department and your staff have been working
diligently over the last 15 years to move
reorganization items away from your responsibility.
And the criterion for that are items that have
state interest or don't have state interest.
The most recent change we had was that the
legislature has removed appeals of disapprovals
of territory transfers from things that come to you.
Basically, the legislature has stated that a
disapproval of a territory transfer locally is not
a state issue.
Now, this appeal was filed before that legislation
went into effect, so you've got to consider it
despite the fact that the legislature has said it's
not of interest to you.
Petitioner reasons for the transfer, you can see
the schools, the boundary line is the dark, heavy
dark line that runs right through the middle there
and the proposed transfer area is a little red
triangle in the lower part of the screen and the
schools in question are identified, outlined in
red with little school houses.
So the petitioner reason for transfer of San Jose
Unified Schools are more distant.
The schools in Oak Grove and Eastside Union High
School are along the parents' daily commute
routes.
They work in that area, at least one of the parents
work over in that area.
And the residents believe they have a greater
sense of community identity with Oak Grove
Elementary and with the Eastside Union High
School District.
Now, at the risk of ruining the ending, we're
going to recommend that you affirm the action of
the county committee to disapprove this
territory transfer and I'll bring this
recommendation up again later.
All the affected school districts are pretty
large districts and if you look at district-wide
comparisons based on racial, ethnic and SES
issues, there's not a whole lot of difference.
Certainly there are some differences but the
districts look relatively similar when we look at
these issues on a district-wide basis.
We'll come back to school-wide comparisons a
little later.
You might recall from previous reorganization
issues that there are nine minimum standards that
a district reorganization have to meet before the
county committee or the state board to consider
whether or not to approve the reorganization.
The county committee found that all nine of those
standards were substantially met but again,
these standards are not the criteria for approval
of a territory transfer.
Once the thresholds are determined to be met, the
county committee needed to examine the issues and
find out whether or not there was a compelling
reason to transfer this territory.
In our review of the information,
county committee discussed no compelling reason to
approve.
In fact, they did discuss, one thing they did
discuss was that inter-district transfer
agreements which the parents currently are using
are the more appropriate response to the issues
that the homeowners have here.
The county committee then disapproved the transfer.
All three affected school districts oppose the
transfer, San Jose Unified, Eastside High School
District, Union High School District and the
Oak Grove Elementary School District.
Primarily they're concerned that these piecemeal
transfers just aren't the way to deal with
parental preferences.
Boundary changes are not like flipping a switch,
boundaries change.
A lot of work goes into a boundary change and when
you're doing that with just parental preferences
for one school or one school district over the
other, it doesn't make sense to use a territory
transfer process.
And again, the inter-district attendance
agreements which the districts all give freely.
San Jose Unified approves over a thousand
inter-district transfers every year.
The parents in this group have gotten transfers
from the district approved every year.
Oak Grove and Eastside state, hey, you know,
we're in declining enrollment, we're not
going to turn students down.
Basically the only reason that they're going to
turn down or disapprove inter-district transfer
agreement according to what they say is if there
are some disciplinary issues with the students.
And additionally, even though they don't think
there are any real general issues or community
wide issues here, if there are, moving to homes
doesn't address them.
It just simply moves the boundary a couple
of homes over.
The appellants had, or the petitioners had two
primary reasons in their appeal.
One is they were denied due process.
They didn't feel that the county committee told
them why they're disapproving the
territory transfer.
They didn't get a written response from the
county committee regarding the reasons for the
procedural issues such as that.
And they didn't believe that the county
committee members used facts to make their
decisions, that they substituted personal opinions.
Well, you know, the education code identifies
things that can be appealed.
These procedural issues are not things that can
be appealed.
Regardless, we took a look at the concerns and we
find there's no basis even for these reasons.
They weren't denied due process.
County committee members, just like state board
members, can approve or disapprove a reorganization
for any reason.
One thing that I'm sure you know is that the
legislature, through the Constitution, is given
responsibility for district boundaries in the state.
They have turned that over to you and to the
county committee.
So anything that you do regarding district
organization is a quasi-legislative proceeding.
You don't have to really, I mean, basically you
don't have to explain yourself.
Okay, so again I mentioned the county committee
found that all the minimum standards were met.
We're not going to look at those because we agree
that they've met.
The petitioners aren't arguing that issue.
The districts don't take any issue with those
findings.
So all we're going to say is we concur with the
findings of the county committee on the 35753
minimum standards.
But again, meeting those standards is not the
reason that you use to approve a reorganization.
The legislature has given us some intent.
Local educational needs and concerns will serve as
a basis for future reorganization of
districts in each county.
So we need to look at reasons beyond the nine
minimum standards to approve a territory transfer.
To approve it, you need to reverse the local action
to disapprove.
And two of the reasons to reverse have been
supplied by the petitioners.
They believe they have a greater sense of
community with the Oak Grove Elementary School
District and the Eastside Union High School
District.
And commutes to schools in Oak Grove and Eastside
are closer than our commutes to the schools
in San Jose Unified.
We'll look at those two.
We have a yellow boundary line between the
district, a blue oval showing the two homes.
Regarding community identity, we have a
difficult time seeing how those two homes have a
greater sense of community identity with the homes
to the east of them compared to the homes to
the west of them or across the street.
It's just for us, that's a non-issue.
Commutes to schools, as you can see here, as you
saw earlier, San Jose Unified schools are more
distant than Oak Grove Elementary schools.
But I mentioned there at the bottom of the slide
that the differences do not meet local standards
for extreme hardship.
Here's what I mean by that.
Santa Clara County is kind of the center of
territory transfers in the state of California.
You've heard 76 territory transfer appeals since
1994.
28 of them, more than a third, have come, have
involved Santa Clara County.
So they have a lot of experience with
territory transfer issues.
Almost every territory transfer proposal that
comes forward to them addresses issues of
schools being closer in the adjacent district.
And that's true, almost any boundary you have.
You go north from the transfer area up until
where the boundary cuts over west, you're going
to find homes in the Oak Grove and the Eastside
Junior High School District that are closer to
San Jose Unified schools than they are to Oak
Grove and San Jose and Eastside Junior High
School Districts.
That's the nature of boundaries.
Whether it's a school district or a city, it's
always going to be something on the other
side of the boundary that's closer to you than
what you have in your own city, your own district.
So in response to that understanding and the
sheer volume of territory transfers the County
Committee has dealt with, they came up with their
own local standards for what constitutes a
hardship for parents in terms of distance traveled.
And these distances do not beat the local
standards for hardship.
So we don't see any reason to overturn the County
Committee's decision, but we do have a couple of
concerns that support that decision to disapproved
the territory transfer.
And these are issues we bring up almost every time.
The reorganization moves students into schools
with higher socioeconomic status.
And the reorganization could establish a precedent
for future reorganizations.
I mentioned earlier that district-wide, the
districts don't look that different.
But if you look at the actual schools that serve
the area and that would serve the area, there is a
big difference.
This is very similar to what you dealt with last
November when we had an Orange County transfer
appeal.
Just looking at the elementary school, the San
Jose Unified Elementary School is 60%
socioeconomically disadvantaged versus 11%
at the Oak Grove Elementary School.
27% English language learners versus 15%.
58% eligibility for free and reduced price meals
versus 11% or 10.5%.
And those differences are constant throughout the
school types and across the different
socioeconomic indicators.
So that's a concern.
We always have that as a concern.
A precedent for future transfers, this is not a
real big issue, but whenever you're using the
territory transfer process to address individual
parental preferences and you have, and that becomes
kind of wide knowledge.
If it becomes successful, then you do have the
possibility that other individual families are
going to use this process to get to the schools
they want, especially when you have schools that
you can transfer into that are of a higher
socioeconomic status.
So it's not a big issue, but it's still a concern
that we deal with.
Let's skip that one.
I've already kind of touched on it.
So finally, our findings.
Again, all the minimum standards are met.
County committee found no compelling reasons for
approval while considering the fact that
inter-district attendance permits are a more
appropriate response for the parents' issues as
the same opinion the school districts have.
The appellants presented no valid reasons for their
appeal, and the CDE, we do not find any reason or
concern compelling enough to reverse the county
committee disapproval of the transfer, but we do
identify some reasons that we think support that
decision of the county committee.
And so we think the local disapproval should be
allowed to stand.
Again, our recommendation is that you affirm the
action of the county committee to disapprove
the proposal to transfer territory from the
San Jose Unified School District to the Oak Grove
Elementary School District and the East Side
Junior High School District.
Be happy to take any clarifying questions if
you have any.
If not, I'll be here to answer other questions
following the public hearing.
I think we're going to, at this point, open the
public hearing at 10.55 a.m.
And we will hear from the petitioners who are in
favor of the territory transfer.
They'll have 10 minutes to make their presentation.
I understand they'll be presenting virtually.
And after the presentation, we'll open up the
phone line for public comment and also take
public comment in the boardroom for those who
are not part of either presentation.
If the petitioners are queued up, you may begin.
Do we have the petitioners?
There we go.
Hi there, can you hear me?
Yes, we can.
Thank you very much.
Yes.
Perfect.
Sorry, just for consideration, would you be
bringing up the presentation I shared with
Mr. Larry earlier?
Would you be bringing that up?
I believe it's coming up.
Thank you.
Perfect.
I just was trying to understand the process.
Thank you.
There you go.
Perfect.
Thank you.
Thank you very much for your time and this
opportunity to speak to you.
We appreciate the process that has been put
forward to enable this.
Please let me preface this, that the contents are
specific to our situation and needs.
It's been over three years since this appeal was
made and lots has changed.
This difficult and trying time was not easy for
anyone.
The sudden disruption of routine in the world of
children resulted in anxiety for many children,
including ours, something we're still trying to
recover from.
Our neighborhood relationships became stronger
and this became more evident as our eldest
started attending Oak Grove School District on
your transfer.
These types of activities where you have
interaction of children, even though they've only
met each other over springtime or as they're
walking by your neighbor, they're only possible
when you live within the school community in which
you reside.
These activities have carried out and established
long relationships with our neighbors and other
members of the community.
Could we go to slide two, please?
During the county meetings, we heard the school
district officials mention that they want
consistency and reliability.
And just like the school district, we too are
seeking consistency and reliability for our
children.
We're a block of four homes that have been
separated into two separate districts.
So we are four neighboring homes with a fence line
that divides the school boundaries.
The experiences of the children in the two
homes from those on the other side of the fence
are different simply because of where the
fence line lies.
This Oak Grove Eastside Union High School District
has provided routine familiarity and a strong
sense of community, belonging and friendships
that started during COVID and continue to flourish
today.
We request you please to allow this transfer so
that we can continue to thrive with certainty.
Our request is about our families and doing what
is right for our kids.
It is difficult to explain and understand why a
block of homes would be divided into two separate
districts by moving these two homes into Oak Grove
and Eastside Union High School District.
The current fence line boundary would move to
where Colleen Drive intersects the Valley
Glen Drive, uniting the four homes under the same
school district.
Next slide, please.
This image is very similar to the one that was
provided by Mr. Larry, just a little bit different
in terms of the visuals.
A is where our homes are located and everything in
blue is showing the physical locations of the
three Oak Grove and Eastside Union High School
District schools.
Please note this isn't exaggerated.
It looks, as you just saw from Mr. Larry, it looks
almost identical to what he was presenting with the
exception of the colors.
Being able to attend a school in your
neighborhood, in our neighborhood, has allowed
us to have greater participation in school
related activities for the children as well as us
as parents.
We've learned so much more about the communities
and the school.
Since actively attending within Oak Grove School
District, we were hoping for a great school
experience for the kids when we first filed for
the territory transfer.
But since actually being able to attend Oak Grove
School District, the experience proved to be
beyond what we had imagined.
The positive and thriving environment would not be
possible when attending the assigned schools of
San Jose Unified School District.
The closest school is further than the
furthest of Oak Grove and Eastside Union High,
thus requiring us to drive our children to and
from school.
There are no safe or commutable ways by which
children could walk or bike to these schools.
Not only are these schools not within our
community, each of the assigned schools are
located within three separate communities with
no real connection with each other or the
community of which we live in.
The assigned middle school, as you can see on
the bottom left of the slide, is a commute that
requires travel over the hills into Elmenden Valley.
This is a commute that is completely removed from
anything that we, anywhere we go, anything we do.
This is not a neighborhood that we even
travel through or have gone through.
The assigned high school, seen at the top of the
slide, requires travel on major streets and at one
point would require children on bikes or
walking to have to cross a freeway access road
that's requiring us to drive our children daily
to and from school.
Prior to transferring into the Oak Grove School
District, we were on a transfer, as Mr. Larry
mentioned, into Evergreen School District, again,
another school outside the neighborhood in which
we reside, which truly gave us an understanding of
the stark difference in attending a school within
your community versus a school completely
isolated from the community in which you reside.
When the safest and most reliable and healthiest
solution is all within walking distance from
within our neighborhood, why create uncertainty
and inconsistencies?
As mentioned previously by both within this
presentation and by Mr. Larry, we are currently
on inter-district transfers between
funds they unified in Oak Grove.
The children walk to and from school along with
their peers and friends and this experience has
been, again, much more amazing than we could
have imagined.
The inter-district transfer is not a long-term
solution for us.
This is, there is no certainty.
The transfer criteria only identifies criteria for
school ages K through five, the transfer nor the
criteria provide a solution or a path to
finishing elementary school or anything beyond
fifth grade.
The only eligibility criteria that we meet today
is that I am employed within the Oak Grove
School District boundaries and jobs are never
guaranteed.
What happens to the transfer criteria for future
years or if my employment ends or changes?
To the, oh sorry, I'm on the next slide, I apologize.
There we go.
Sorry about that.
The solution is unreliable.
These transfers are annual application process
with no guarantees of acceptance year over
year.
Yes, you know, folks will mention that you're in,
but there's no written assurance of parents.
There's no 100% guarantee understood that it may be
based on, you know, the child and if they have any
issues within school.
But even having that in writing is not available.
Children are, sorry, and the other unreliability on
this is that by the time the school district notify
you of approval, it's too late to sign up for
after school programs or care as enrollment for
that happens much earlier in the year versus when
receipt of acceptance is provided.
Children are also at a disadvantage when they're
on an inter-district school transfer for
district-based programming.
A preference is given and first choice is given to
those children who reside within the school
district boundaries.
So the resident children are provided the preference
for first choice.
But next slide, please.
So we believe that the Santa Clara County
Committee did not make the right decision as it is
difficult to understand how this could be rejected
if the facts including the recommendations of the
county office were considered.
The committee did not, either in writing or
verbally, provide any evidence or explanation or
reasoning for the rejection.
Upon leaving the meeting, we were confused and still
don't understand what the grounds for rejection was
or were.
What we recall of the discussion among the
committee members was their personal experience
as school-aged children.
It was not apparent how the decision took into
consideration the uniqueness of this boundary
and or the findings of the county itself.
The Santa Clara County office clearly demonstrated
or concluded that all the criteria, as Mr. Larry
mentioned, was met, that the number of school-aged
children who could live in these two homes would not
significantly impact enrollment at the districts.
The declining enrollment in both Oak Grove and
Eastside Union within the transfer barrier
demonstrates no negative impact and, as parents
involved in the school site council, declining
enrollment has been an ongoing discussion.
In the corner of Colleen Drive and Valley Glen
Drive, the cul-de-sac.
Sorry to interrupt, your time is up.
OK, thank you very much.
We appreciate it.
At this point, we do want to open up the phone line
for public comment.
We know they're not going to be here, but I would
like to make a brief statement on the part of
San Jose Unified.
There is a San Jose Unified staff member available
for questions, but the district superintendent
has told me that the district really has no
new information to present beyond what you've
already heard.
So unless they don't think that a repetition of
arguments and information has already been
presented to you is an appropriate use of time,
so they're not going to be taking part in the
public hearing.
Similarly, neither Oak Grove nor Eastside will be
presenting.
OK, thank you.
So at this point, we will open the phone line for
public comment.
We need the public comment slide and we'll also
take public comment in the boardroom for those who
were not part of either presentation.
And so let's see if there's anybody who wants to
make public comment.
There is no public comment in the boardroom.
And is there any public comment on the phone?
There are no callers in the queue.
OK, yes, hello.
We do have somebody.
Yes, actually, I'm the owner of the property 74.
So but I do not prepare the presentation because my
neighbor already prepared the presentation ready
and represented me ready.
But I would like to take a couple of minutes to
emphasize my concerns.
I'm sorry, sir.
You have already 10 minutes, so you do have one
minute if you'd like to speak.
But you only have one minute.
OK, hello.
Is it me?
Go ahead and proceed.
Yeah, so I would like to emphasize the current
school district boundary.
It's actually all my property virtually plus my
fence.
So this boundary divided the small neighborhood
basically four house to the two parties.
It's not a logic and no sense, you know, for
schools, school district divided by the supposed
divided by the, you know, ideally the physical
street.
So the community seems is broken.
For example, the two two house kids, you know,
played together, but they went to the different
school later on.
That was not good.
Also, school are, you know, far away from my homes
across major basing, you know, the basis tree,
even freeway.
It has no safe for parents and for children with
a busy traffic.
But the school are all the walk distance, sir.
Your time is up.
Thank you.
And that concludes public comment for item number
13.
So this point I want to open, I want to close the
public hearing at 1110 a.m.
And then we will begin board discussion.
I'd first like to ask our liaison member Escobedo
if he would like to make some initial comments.
I believe the presentation is very clear.
We're looking at two homes, both the county and
the district feels that you stay close to your
mic so we can hear.
There shouldn't be any any changes to the
boundaries.
And then really, I mean, I think the
presentation was very clear.
Thank you so much for for all the information you
provided.
Any thoughts or comments?
I think we're ready now for clarifying questions
and board discussions.
So, yes, as President Glover would.
Just a couple of questions in relation to the
boundary itself.
If I'm understanding the presentation correctly,
this is a boundary that is not set by a street,
but by a fence line.
Is that correct, Mr. Sharpe?
Correct.
Let me just go back a moment here.
Right, the boundary is there.
You can't see it here, but the boundary, it runs
because it's a property line there south of Colleen
Drive is a property line between two homes.
OK, and can you tell me, do we happen to know when
that district boundary was drawn?
Was it drawn prior to the homes in that area and
the homes in question, or was that boundary line
drawn after those homes were existing?
I wouldn't know that specifically.
My guess is, though, just by looking at the
boundary line, since it's not, it's at the top
there, it's running along the rear property line
of homes on two streets on either side.
It's the property line and it's running along a
parcel line that it's highly likely that the
boundary was drawn after the homes were built.
Because otherwise, parcels would be split and it
wouldn't be that clean distinction.
But that's just without knowing for sure, that
would be my guess.
OK, thank you.
Thank you.
Any questions or comments?
I guess I'd love to hear, since we haven't heard
from the district or the county, the plaintiff
asked the question, like, what is the reason that
they wanted to deny the request?
And there seemed to be lack of clarity about that.
Maybe you could clear that up.
Do you want to speak with the district
representative on that?
I can answer.
Representing their views, yeah.
In terms of inter-district transfer requests, I
am not quite sure, I don't quite understand the
concerns that were raised by the appellant in
indicating that the process is not available
after fifth grade.
Inter-district transfers are for all grade levels,
K through 12.
I'm sure most of you know that.
Regarding her concern that the transfer process
for her is going to end at fifth grade, if she's
got an employment-based inter-district transfer,
what we used to call the Allen Bill transfers,
those are in statute.
Once you get them, you don't have to reapply.
So I'm not quite understanding what's going
on there, and they're good until 12th grade.
In the case of Oak Grove School District, they're
not a 9-12 district, but they're good for the
entire attendance of the students.
In terms of, I think you were asking why, about
denials or disapprovals of transfers?
Well, no, about the idea of moving the territory
boundary.
That's what's being...
I'm sorry, I'm having trouble hearing it.
Why the, sorry?
I know.
I have old ears, so I'm sorry.
The disapproval of the request to move the
boundary, which appears to be between, you know,
across the fence line in a small neighborhood,
what the rationale was for that disapproval?
The rationale primarily was that there's no
compelling reason to do it, and that's...
All the conditions are met, and it's the
responsibility of the county committee to find a
reason to transfer the territory.
They didn't find a reason.
And really, the process can end there.
There's no reason to do it.
We're going to disapprove it.
But they also indicated that, you know, this is
not the appropriate way to use territory transfers,
that the district transfer process is the more
appropriate way to deal with the individual
preferences of the family and their desires for
one school district over another.
Ben?
Yes, Vice President Glover-Woods?
Oh, I want you to finish your sentence.
I'm done.
OK.
I'm still having a little bit of difficulty,
and I definitely appreciate the inter-district
transfer process for preference, most definitely.
And I also appreciate the comments that were given
by the person who was presenting in regards to
some of the challenges with approvals of transfers
and the timelines for some of the other things
that you can avail yourself of.
I want to try to get some clarification with where
I'm struggling here, and to be very honest, it's
the way the boundary line is drawn and how it's
dividing the block.
That is, I think this is where I'm a little bit
challenged to understand why there's no compelling
reason when we're dividing a block in this way,
especially if that line was drawn after those
houses were already there, if that is indeed the case.
Well, you know, I don't know if you can really
see it clearly here, but the petitioners, the
appellants talked about four homes, two on, and we
can't pull up their petition, their
presentation right now, two homes on one side of
the boundary, two homes on the other side of the
boundary, and then on the one side of the two
homes, there's a cul-de-sac.
On the other side of the other two homes is
another cul-de-sac, and their issue is that we
should, it's hard to describe without being
able to show it to you, but it's going to divide
the community no matter where the boundary is
going to go.
If you do what they want, it's still going to
separate homes in that community from one
district to another.
Well, here it is, yeah, here it is.
So, as you see here, 786, 784, 782, 780, the
boundary, current boundaries in red divides
those four homes.
On the west side, 6204 and 6208 are homes on the
Valley Glen Drive, which is a cul-de-sac.
On the other side of 780 is another cul-de-sac,
two homes, so everybody has fence lines there.
If you move the boundary to where they want, which
is the left green line, then they're still
separating the community.
This is helpful.
I mean, it's still a fence line.
I mean, it is, they're not, their driveways aren't
facing on the same street, but they're homes that
are right next to them.
This helps to clarify.
Similarly, you're going to have homes right across
the street that look onto these homes, you know.
So, it's just kind of, in terms of a community
identity issue, we just don't quite understand it
because you move the boundary and you still
have the same issue.
Thank you.
And I'd like to add that this is commonplace.
Sometimes these boundaries are created 50, 60, 70
years ago, and in my former district, I had, you
know, within a block, one or two districts adjoining.
So, this is not a rare occurrence.
This does happen because these boundaries were set
a long time before some of these homes or sometimes
neighborhoods were established.
Yeah, I mean, there are many, many instances
where boundary lines run right through homes.
So, right through, yeah, I mean, that's just it.
You know, the boundary lines are drawn,
housing development comes in.
You get the bedroom on one side, you go to one
district and you get the other bedroom.
Leave it alone.
All right.
Do we have any other questions or comments
before we take a motion?
I'm not seeing any questions or.
Did I miss anything?
All right.
So, do we have a motion?
Member Escobedo.
I would like to motion for us to affirm the decision
of the county committee to disapprove the proposal
to transfer territory from San Jose to Oak Grove
and the east side, UHSD.
And I second that.
All right.
Any further discussion of the motion?
All in favor, raise your hand and say aye.
Aye.
Any opposed?
Any abstentions?
The motion carries.
Thank you very much.
At this point, thank you, Larry.
We appreciate you.
We'd like to reopen item one to take action
on the preliminary report of actions
draft May 2023 meeting minutes
and to report on our liaison assignments.
And while we're waiting for any members of the public
to call in, we need the public comment slide up, please.
Thank you very much.
Do I have a motion from a board member
to approve the May 2023 State Board of Education
draft preliminary report of action meeting minutes?
Member Olken, do I have a second?
Member Rodriguez, thank you.
Is there any public comment?
Either in person or on the phone.
There are no callers in the queue.
And no people in the room?
And there's nobody in the room.
All right.
Is there any further discussion?
Seeing none, show of hands and say aye.
If you're in favor, aye.
Any opposed?
Any abstentions?
Okay.
Member Teal-Bronson and Member McClellan will abstain.
All right, motion carries.
Thank you.
Now I want to invite our State Board members
to report out on their liaison activities
that are not related to any items on our July agenda.
And we're going to start with member Escobedo.
Yes, sir.
I wish to remind the board,
NASBE Conference will be on October 25th to 28th.
It will be in San Diego, California.
We had a actual meeting with SBE staff
to talk about entertainment and speakers
that can well represent California.
We also have a proposal submitted
on our community schools,
or we'll find out if it will be accepted by this month,
and we'll be having a follow-up meeting
within the next few weeks to discuss further plans
to highlight California during this conference.
So if you haven't done it already,
please register yourself again October 25th to the 28th.
Again, it's the only conference designed
specifically for State Board members.
My work as a liaison for WestEd,
we are in preparation for the upcoming CEO hiring.
Every board member, including myself,
went through an extensive implicit bias training,
and next week we'll be interviewing three finalists,
and hopefully by the end of the month
we will know who the new CEO for WestEd will be.
And my colleagues, President Darling-Hammond,
and Trustee, oh my God, I'd leave.
We had just a great time preparing
for Senate confirmation as well.
So we did well, I think we did exceedingly well.
So it was truly an amazing experience
and just glad to be part of the process.
Thank you.
Perfect, thank you.
We'll go to Vice President Glover-Woods.
Thank you.
Just to let you know,
for the Instructional Quality Commission,
that meeting, they did not meet since our May meeting,
so there will be no report until our September meeting
in regards to that commission.
And as far as the California Collaborative
for Educational Excellence, also known as CCEE,
have a couple of things to share with you.
And again, the CCEE is quite busy in their work,
even during these times when schools are off.
Did want to share with you
that the direct technical assistance webpage
now includes the progress updates
for the May 2023 fourth quarter.
And if you are interested,
you can definitely go to that webpage
and review the progress of the current districts
that are receiving direct technical assistance.
And to date, the districts that are receiving
that direct technical assistance are Inglewood,
Vallejo City, Salinas, Sacramento,
Oakland, and Mount Diablo.
Also, the CCEE has been helping to facilitate
the high-quality online instructional materials,
and the Kern County Superintendent of Schools,
along with the CDE and CCEE,
is nearing completion of the first year
of that high-quality online instructional materials project,
as well as the use of a rubric
to help evaluate high-quality online materials for educators.
There is also an annual report for the CCEE.
If you would like to read it,
I would definitely encourage you to do so.
You will find that online on the CCEE webpage,
and it was presented during our June CCEE governing board meeting,
as well as an update from all of the centers.
And again, in all of your free time,
would encourage you to even take a look at that recording.
There are a lot of great things happening at each of the centers.
There's one other piece that I did want to share with you
as I get ready to conclude,
and I have to look on this, I apologize.
As I'm getting this other information ready for you,
I do want to let you know that the CCEE
will be resuming in-person meetings.
We've been meeting virtually,
and our first meeting in person for the new year
will be on August 31st.
The last piece that I wanted to add in
is to let you know that the CCEE
just launched the Levers 2.0 LEA inventory.
That's an expanded version of the Basic Levers
special education inventory for LEAs,
and the tool is available online at the CCEE website,
and it's really in place,
and we encourage LEAs that are wanting to improve
and align systems for general and special education
to go online and take a look at that tool.
Again, another helpful resource, and that concludes my report.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Member Lewis.
Okay, thank you.
I am the liaison to the California Subject Matter Project
and Currents Committee,
and I will give a brief report on the June quarterly meeting.
And for those of you who are not aware
of the individuals and groups that comprise this project,
it consists of the California Arts Project,
which is headquartered in CSU San Bernardino,
the California Global Education Project,
which is headquartered at the University of San Diego,
the California History Social Science Project,
headquartered at UC Davis,
the California Mathematics Project at UCLA,
the California Physical Education and Health Project
at CSU Channel Islands,
the California Reading and Literature Project at UC San Diego,
the California Science Project at UC Riverside,
the California World Language Project
headquartered at Stanford University,
and the California Writing Project
headquartered at UC Santa Barbara.
And these nine disciplines, they work specific networks
that consist of 80 regional sites
that serve approximately 25,000 educators
for more than 1,200 school districts on an annual basis.
The CSMP is committed to growing their role
in providing a more robust statewide support system
led by the executive directors
of each of the mentioned projects.
And today I'll just share some of the highlights
from the June meeting.
The committee started off with an appreciation
of the former California Reading and Literature Project
executive director, Debra Costa-Hernandez,
and welcomed the new executive director,
Shirvana Anderson-Bird,
who has been a regional CRLP director for the past 13 years.
The committee also provided a few highlights
of several of the statewide cross-disciplinary initiatives
that are now in different stages of implementation,
and they include programming around ethnic studies
and computer science.
The CMP also continues to partner
with the 21st CSLA Leadership Academy
and has formed a new partnership
with the California Initiative Collaborative,
a statewide collaborative with intersegmental partners,
looking at recommendations to create various options
for mathematics, articulation,
and pathways to higher education.
This is a very busy group, and during that meeting,
each of the SMP leads provided updates on their current work.
And if you'd like more information,
you can visit the CSMP link to each of the projects
with an explanation of the work that's going on.
And thank you, and that concludes my report.
Member Olken.
Thank you.
I am going to focus my comments today
in the spirit of gay math
after our successful adoption yesterday.
So I'm just going to talk about two...
My two liaison reports are sort of related to math.
First, I am the liaison for the SMP,
liaison for environmental literacy,
and I attended the quarterly accountability meeting
of the Climate Change and Environmental Justice Program.
This is a project which stems from a budget allocation
of $6 million to create free open source curricular units
at every grade level, focusing on climate change,
environmental justice, and ensuring that kids
at all levels are doing hands-on action-oriented work
to become better stewards
and understanding the role that they can play.
And it's being overseen by the San Mateo County Office of Education,
and the work is being led by 10 strands.
So the update is that the work to create all these units
is moving smoothly.
There are community partners across the state
who are actually building the units,
and they're getting ready to do sort of test implementations,
pilot programs in schools.
We got to see the design of the units,
which is based on big questions.
They are interdisciplinary, so this gets back to math,
because all of the units have standards
that come from different disciplines across the curricula.
And so yesterday, the founder of 10 strands was here talking about
how the environmental literacy standards
are incorporated into the new math framework,
and that goes both directions.
So that's really exciting work.
And then the other thing is I was lucky to attend
the Early Math Initiative Symposium,
which is the Early Math Project is a statewide partnership
that promotes the importance of math and early education
birth through age eight
by providing tools to parents and educators
and collaborates with agencies across the state
to promote mathematical thinking and joy in math.
The symposium was incredible.
It was intended by 3,000 educators from across California,
as well as a large national and international audience.
And in case anybody here or out there listening missed it,
they have another event coming up in the fall,
which is a free virtual fall forum on October 8th.
And so if that's something you're interested in,
you want to look at the Early Math...
Hold on, I even have the link.
Well, you want to look at the Early Math Initiative website.
And yesterday, we heard one of my favourite quotes from yesterday
was, first of all, yay math.
That was my first favourite quote.
But my second one is that fun and rigor can coexist.
And I think we don't always remember that in the math classroom,
but they always remember that in the Early Math Initiative
and the work that they do.
And I think that's a really important piece
of strengthening every child's excitement
and how many kids are going to come and say, I love math.
So, and with that, that concludes my report.
And for the meeting is yay math.
Member Roscoe Gonzalez.
Hi, everyone.
So I am the assessment committee liaison
and I shared during our item three discussion
that the redesigned score reports for CASP and ALPAC
are a positive test step towards improving test result reporting.
The efforts made by the CDE and the ETS to involve students,
educators, parents and guardians in focus groups
and feedback opportunities are commendable.
The feedback received has resulted in a clearer,
more accessible reports with less jargon, less text.
The use of colour and graphics will enhance visual appeal
and understanding.
I already received the reports early on in June for my own children.
So I thought that already there is some step forward.
The inclusion of school and state averages for scale,
score comparison and the consolidation of ELA and mathematics
and science results into one report,
simplify the information and provide valuable context.
The introduction of composite claim reporting for ELA
and mathematics offers a comprehensive view
of student performance.
The commitment to continuous improvement
and user-friendly designs is evident.
And I want to highlight again that the educators will have access
to over 200 assessment forms through the 23-24 Smarter Balance
interim assessments for ELA and math starting August 1st,
just in time for the school year to start our planning.
The Tools for Teachers website provides instructional resources
including grade level performance descriptions
and academic vocabulary list to support educators
in enhancing their teaching practices
and meeting the diverse needs of their students.
I say are because, you know, I'm in the classroom.
These resources are aligned with the interim assessments
providing valuable guidance for instruction.
Now my recommendation is that it would be beneficial
to include English language development, teacher resources
and the Tools for Teachers website
and that the student score reports are available
in multiple languages with further improved accessibility
and inclusivity.
So that concludes my report.
Thank you.
Member Porter.
So I'm just going to share a few highlights from my work.
The first that I was able to meet with the Youth Commission
for the City of San Jose about opportunities for young people
to get involved on not only the statewide level
but locally as well and how to leverage their passions
and turn them into passion projects and talents
to make their school a better and more safe environment.
Second, I was able to meet with the California Association
of Student Councils three different regional conferences
as well as their summer camp to share with young leaders
about how to start their journey within school districts
and this is for freshmen, sophomores, juniors and seniors
and just informing them about resources available to students
as they continue their leadership journeys.
And lastly, I've been able to train my successor Anya
with meetings and by creating a Google Drive of information
about organizations she should connect with,
advisory groups to work with, people to connect with
and the best ways to maximize her time here on the State Board.
And so thank you again to each of you for the ways
that you've impacted me indirectly and directly during my term.
I know that I will come back to California
because of people like you
and just continue to live a life of service.
So thank you.
That concludes my report.
All right.
Thank you.
Member Rodriguez.
So we are currently, I'm the co-chair
for the NASB's PEP, Public Education Policy Committee
and what our team is working on is high school redesign
and rethinking how to make high schools more relevant
and more engaging for our youth
who reported a disconnection at times
with their high schools as they are.
Sometimes they feel unprepared.
And so we're rethinking and looking at models that are effective,
such as when teachers have a chance to collaborate together,
when schools are a little more intimate,
closed for teachers to work with a small group of students.
And what we're working on,
we're looking at research and listening to experts.
And then we'll be presenting this at the conference
that Member Escobedo talked about in October.
So it's exciting work and it's important work
for our young people and for our teachers as well.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Member Yoshimoto-Towry.
Good afternoon, everybody. I have two reports.
I passed by alphabetically. I passed by.
Member Patil-Bronson.
Please.
OK.
I'm just looking at my alphabetical list and it's like...
Go ahead.
Member Yoshimoto-Towry.
I was always last in elementary school.
I have a complex about that.
So good afternoon, everybody.
Two brief reports, one on the Advisory Commission for Special Education.
And I'm happy to report that the commissioners voted a new chair in,
and Chair David Tustin, who many of you know is eager to align
the work of the Advisory Commission on Special Education with our work.
And an example of that is they added a meeting in December
to be able to advise us on the annual performance report
that will come to us in January.
So in time to give us their advice.
Secondly, the community schools effort.
I just wanted to share that there was an inspiring community school summit
on June 16th in San Francisco.
There were thousands of educators there from across California and the nation.
And I think what made it so phenomenal is that the breakout sessions
were led by teachers, by parents, by community school coordinators,
administrators, people from county offices.
And it really showed the collaboration and the community school effort
across the state and the country.
So thank you.
And I'm going to go to Member Patilla Bronson,
but I also, my alphabeticalist did not include Member McQuillan,
so I'm going to come back to you.
I think you're just keeping us on our toes.
Yeah, I think it's a good idea.
So one of the liaison assignments I have is with the Universal Pre-K Mixed Delivery Workgroup,
which focuses on both the expansion of transitional kindergarten
as well as the expansion of the California State Preschool Program.
It's exciting to see that UTK has been rolling out
and is expected to serve about 300,000 four-year-olds
by the 25-26 school year.
What we're seeing is about 10% of school districts and charter schools
are expanding faster than expected,
enrolling four-year-olds even sooner than required by law,
which I think is an exciting sign of interest
and also capacity on the part of local implementing districts,
and that about 80% of districts are offering full-day transitional kindergarten,
even though they're not officially required to,
but I think the research certainly demonstrates
that that is a laudable aspiration to bring into implementation.
In addition, the state budget,
which I think we described somewhat earlier in the...
I guess that was just yesterday,
also includes continuing eligibility expansions
in terms of the number of birthdays that are included
as we're rolling into or towards 25-26,
and the budget also included funding to add one certificated
or classified staff person to every TK class
to reduce the adult-to-child ratios
to align more closely with the state preschool program.
It's also a cost-of-living adjustment,
which has not always been the case
that the early side of the House has gotten the same COLA,
and I think it's a huge sign of respect, honestly,
to have that mirrored across the different systems.
The latest breaking and connected to school districts,
but somewhat sort of apart,
is the childcare side of the world,
which really is the feeder system.
Before kids come into the TK to 12 side of the House,
received a huge, really largest pay increase in state history
for childcare providers.
It's estimated to be about $600 million
and rate increases over two years,
plus starting the first-ever $80 million retirement funding pot
and $100 million for healthcare funding.
Again, these are things that are normal in the world of K-12,
but are new for the earliest side of early learning,
and I think really exciting.
The last is that, again, as distinct from the K-12 system,
there are family fees that are charged for childcare,
so there's a cap for the lowest-income families
to no longer have to pay higher amounts per month,
but capping at 1% of family income again.
That is super exciting.
In addition, for the liaison work on school facilities,
there was a UC Berkeley forum on school facilities
and modernization and inequity problems
in the modernization funding,
which Jeff Vincent from UC Berkeley
was the primary featured guest.
Really drawing upon getting down to facts,
work from a couple years back
around why disparities in school facilities funding
that are due to local property wealth and property values,
and pointing out the degree to which it's effectively
a regressive finance system that makes it very difficult
for lower-income districts and lower-property districts
to be able to access modernization funds.
The big headline number that certainly caught my attention
is that the most poverty-poor or property-poor districts
have about $400 per student in terms of bonding capacity
versus wealthy districts or property-wealthy districts
have almost $800,000 per student,
and the messages that are sent to kids
when their facilities are allowed to fall into disrepair,
I think, are significant.
So there are a host of proposals being considered
to look at changing the share of local contribution
versus state contribution to take account for the fact
that there are a lot of property-poor areas of the state,
and it's not an urban rural, it's really across the state
that this problem has been percolating.
But really looking at modifying the sliding scale proposal
that is already actually baked into prior legislation
to even the odds and make the system a little less regressive.
And that concludes my report.
And Member McQuillan.
Thank you.
My assignment that I want to report back on
is the model curriculum liaison assignment.
The first one is from Orange County Office of Education
which is leading the model curriculum development
on Cambodian genocide model curriculum,
the Hmong history and cultural studies curriculum,
and the Vietnamese American refugee experience.
Orange County has conducted lots of listening sessions
and input sessions over the last year
and is now in the drafting period this summer
of drafting that model curriculum
on those three communities.
Very interesting, very insightful,
learning about these three communities.
And then this fall, that draft curriculum
will come back to the committees for feedback
and then finalizing in the spring of 2024.
The other model curriculum is being developed
by Humboldt County Office of Ed
and San Diego County Office of Ed
on American Indian curriculum.
That's taking a little more time to bake
and over the next two years.
And lots of listening sessions there
conducted by Humboldt County and San Diego.
And then developing new curriculum,
grabbing a hold of existing curriculum
and lots of listening sessions there.
Again, that'll take two years on that.
The other report is on the career technical education.
We have a new statewide plan
on career technical education.
That's a report from the Joint Pathways Committee
that I also sit on.
And that statewide plan will be rolling out now
over the next few months.
And I urge you to take a look at that.
Thank you.
Exciting progress being made.
And I've said plenty in this meeting.
I will simply just add to all the work
that we've already discussed that
in the accountability domain,
which I am a co-leason for,
we've begun to think about also
the continuous instruction approach
that we started to take at the beginning of the pandemic,
asking districts to be able to have a plan
for how they can move in and out of instruction.
We didn't really talk about that yesterday,
but that's another piece of the puzzle
that is really not about accountability or dashboard.
It's about how do we deal with the kind of changes
in climate and so on.
Back in the beginning of the pandemic,
the place that appeared as the most interesting
in that regard was Miami,
because they had had the beginnings of floods every year.
So they had a plan for every school
that students would have laptops,
they would have all of the assignments and everything
up on the dashboard,
the chalkboard or whatever it is that they were using
for online instruction,
and could flexibly be in and out of school.
And as we were talking about the ways in which we want to
support attendance,
part of it is going to be beyond our dashboard
or indicator system,
but really into the way we help support schools
to be able to do that.
So interesting conversations are going on about that,
not only here, but across the country.
And we'll have a chance to talk more about that in future.
And now I'd like to take up agenda item 16,
general public comment.
Public comment is invited on any matter
not included on the printed agenda.
Are there any speakers signed up
to provide public comment in person?
Yes, Steve McDougall.
Nice to see you again.
There we go.
I think it's afternoon.
Good afternoon, members of the board, CD staff,
Steve McDougall with the California Federation of Teachers.
We are two weeks away from some of our schools opening up,
five weeks away from all of them being open probably.
And it'll be our first full year of AI
being on students' and staff's brains.
We really need to have some guidance out there for LEAs
on what to do about it and what not to do about it.
Certainly with our academic honesty,
honesty policies need to be some guidance on that updated.
But I urge you, if you're not already working on that,
that maybe we need to get going on that.
And if you have been working on it and I just missed it,
I apologize for being redundant.
So, other than that, I'd like you all to adjourn if you can.
Thank you very much, Steve,
both for that knotty problem and for that good advice.
Is there anyone waiting to provide public comment on the phone line?
There is not.
All right.
So there are no further callers.
And I hereby can adjourn our July 2023 meeting at 11.52 a.m.
Thank you. And I look forward to seeing you in September.
Yay!